so today we're going to talk about
tuberculosis and hiv in rural south
africa
the work that i've done there with
the aids program with jerry friedland
with people who are sitting in this room
has been a wonderful
endeavors thus far and i'm happy to be
here to talk more about it
um so the title of the talk is
addressing tb in a high prevalence
setting in rural side i'm going to focus
on the three eyes
i'm not sure how many of you know what
the three eyes are but you will by the
end of this talk
this is just an outline of what we're
going to be talking about today i'll do
some a little bit of background about tb
this is not something that we talk a lot
about here in the us
we'll talk about the setting
what the three eyes are and then
in more detail the actual work that's
being done
so just a little bit about
tuberculosis mycobacterium tuberculosis
is a
bacteria it's an it's a bacteria
mycobacteria
that is
ubiquitous
globally and transmission is is uh
occurs through the air barn route
certainly coughing is something that we
all
recognize
uh sneezing and talking as well can
can generate aerosolized particles from
our respiratory tracts and get it up
into the air where it can then be
inhaled by someone else
and this picture that you can see here
is demonstrating that
it is inhibited by uv light and as such
we generally think of transmission
occurring
in areas where there's little
ventilation little airflow and where
there's little exposure or less exposure
to sunlight
hiv patients within a compromised immune
system are particularly vulnerable
to
hiv infection
and to progression more rapidly to
active disease
so that's also something that will
that's the crux of what we're going to
be talking about today
because of the diminished immune
response that hiv patients have they are
a vulnerable population
it certainly
complicates
co-infection complicates diagnosis and
management of the disease
and unfortunately because of these
issues
tb is a leading cause of death for hiv
patients around the world
just some
general information nearly nine million
cases of tuberculosis globally
in 2010 almost one and a half million
deaths
from tb in 2010
and a significant proportion of those
deaths occur disproportionately occur in
hiv-infected patients
the thing that i'll emphasize here is
that
tb is a treatable disease
we have perfectly good therapies
antibacterial anti-mycobacterial
therapies to treat people with tb
but unfortunately
for a variety of reasons
hiv patients suffer
tremendously
from this disease and
have increased experience increased
mortality
just for reference
i'm putting up some information about
here in the u.s
so you can see that we are down at
historic lows here in the u.s
as of 2010
last available data that we have from
the uscdc
um
it used to be we used to get
you know in the 20 30 000 range cases
per year across the us you see a surge
here in the early 90s
does anybody know what that might be
attributable to
hiv exactly the rise of the hiv epidemic
here in the u.s
but with a lot of investment in the u.s
public health infrastructure we were
able to bring that
uh
get that under control and get this down
year by year again we're down at
historic lows
and these are just the numbers uh for
reference um in 2010 we've had about 11
100 cases um in the u.s and the rate
is 3.6 per hundred thousand in the u.s
and that'll be important number to
remember later on
so again
as a reminder nine million cases
compared to our 11 000 and change here
in the us nine million cases around the
world
approximately 13 hiv co-infection the
vast majority of that burden is in
sub-saharan africa
one and a half million deaths about
again about a quarter of those occurring
in hiv affected patients so there's a
disproportionate response there
unfortunately
among tb patients internationally we
don't know everyone's hiv status
we know that the diseases are
inextricably linked
but
for a variety of reasons
to do in different healthcare systems
the tb people are over here the hiv
people are over here they're very
vertical uh silos in various healthcare
systems and they don't often talk to
each other
even though the patients are one and the
same
so for many years up until just in the
last couple of years
tb among tb patients the hiv testing
wasn't being done
and being documented accordingly so we
only know people's status in about 20
less than a quarter of all
nine million cases
and then another thing that we'll touch
on today is the fact that there's more
than four hundred thousand
cases of mdr tb
uh internationally and that number is
growing
and we'll talk a little bit more about
what mdr tv means in one minute
34 million people living with hiv
internationally
again the vast majority of that is in
sub-saharan africa
two million deaths a year
and very
small proportion of people who need and
are eligible for antiretroviral therapy
are getting it
and this is all background to
for what we're going to be talking about
today
so you can see in this these are who
figures in 2010 the the estimated tb
incidents around the world
the lighter color green is lower
incidence rates and the higher or darker
color greens are indicate higher
incidence rates so again you can see
that we are in the lowest risk uh lowest
category and that's zero to 24
uh cases per hundred thousand and then
you can see
in the darkest color that's more than
300 per hundred
you
thousand
see the darkest color being here
in the world again the vast majority of
the burden is in this part of the world
and similarly
um
same thing the lighter color indicates a
lower uh incidence and a higher color or
darker color indicates a higher uh
rate
higher hiv prevalence and hiv province
in new tb cases is greatest in again in
this part of the world
just to illustrate what we were talking
about
okay some some basic terminology
so when we talk about
mdr tb or multiple drug resistant tb
this means that we're talking about
organisms mycobacterial organisms that
have resistance to
two of the first line tb drugs and
that's isoniazid and rifampin
so that's very important to know
as a result
it becomes much more difficult to treat
and the remaining other options for
therapeutics that we have are less
efficacious more toxic have more
toxicities and the therapy treatment
courses are currently much longer
and there's a much higher mortality rate
associated with mdr tv
xdrtb
defined as is an additional layer of
resistance so mdrtb
plus resistance to a quinolone and an
injectable agent one of the three i'm a
case in ketomycin or capriomycin
so for you guys to understand
those terms and i'll just mention that
this work um
defining or detecting xdr tbr
extensively drug resistant tb uh was
from 2005-2006 reported in the lancet
2007 by uh jerry friedman who just
walked in who i've had the fortune to
work with the last few years
there was 53 patients with xdr tv
identified in tagalog ferry
with a very high rate of mortality
98 within a very short period of time
so since then mdr next year tb have been
reported from south throughout south
africa throughout the world and there
has been a lot more attention paid to
tuberculosis
and again
just to highlight
mdr and the same color scheme goes the
darker the color the higher the rate
the most
in the world has been the burden of mdr
tv has been here and xdrtb you can see
has been detected all over the world
including here in the us and in the rest
of north america so that's not drug
resistant tb is not limited to another
part of the world it's a very real issue
for all of us
so a little bit about south africa the
population of approximately 50 million
and the incidence of tb
is nearly a thousand per hundred
thousand
who remembers what the incidence in the
u.s is
that number i told you to remember
before
i i'm hearing it i think
3.6 per 100 000 absolutely
so just for frame of reference you're
talking about
order magnitude difference here south
africa has
is
leads the world in some of these health
indicators and you know these are
unfortunately not positive indicators
but
fifth in the world in terms of tb cases
fourth in the world in terms of the
amount of drug resistant tb cases and
has the honor being the number one
country in the world or
with the largest
burden of co-infection
hiv and tb cases
more than a third of the
cases
globally
in south africa the estimated mortality
from tb is 50 percent
remember when i said tb is a treatable
disease
and yet in parts of the world more than
half the people who get it are are dying
from that disease
and these are just some photographs of
the area that we work in
it's a very traditional style home
traditional zulu home from the eastern
part of south africa where we work
similarly a traditional zoo home
traditional dress
you can see that this is the status of
most of our roads this is probably a
better one
than most
very dry arid not great for vegetation
though quite beautiful
so
like we talked about what was happening
in the u.s
you can see here that over the last
couple of decades
as the
hiv tb
rates were rather flat and then once the
hiv epidemic rose you could see a
concurrent increase in tb cases
so
in this part of the world
certainly
hiv and tb are inextricably linked
together fairy so to orient you
the african continent
uh south africa is at the southern tip
uh we're looking at the eastern side of
the country
this area that's colored in is
kwazulu-natal province
and the different colors represent
different districts we this is um
zenyatta district this brown color here
and together fairy's
smackdown in the middle of uh
district and cape quasital province
it's approximately three hours inland
from durban which if you're familiar
with air is the largest city
and on the coast approximately here
so this the
taylor fairy area
here is approximately 180 000
traditional zulu people
with a very high hiv antenatal uh
prevalence rate at least one in three
went pregnant women are hiv positive
again the tb incidence in this area uh
is almost eleven hundred per hundred
thousand so higher than the rest of
south africa
and certainly much higher than in the us
they're characterized by
extreme poverty very high unemployment
lack of electricity and lack of access
to clean water
we work in in tagalog ferry where there
is a district government hospital
350 beds
that serves the entire that whole
catchment area 180 000 people
say now moving on to the the three eyes
so the who the world health organization
has promoted a three-pronged approach
for tb control particularly
addressing tb and hiv-infected patients
and that is infection control
intensive case finding and isonized
preventive therapy
and we'll talk about all of these
individually
so to start off we'll talk about
infection control and exactly what that
means
so
tb infection
control we are concerned about
transmission of tuberculosis from one
person to another so it's trying to stop
the spread of tuberculosis between
between and amongst patients and between
patients and healthcare workers and
again to limit the spread the spread of
tb and mdr and xdrtb has been well
described in literature
to
healthcare workers certainly
and
to other patients the xdrtb
epidemic that was initially detected by
dr friedland's work as i mentioned
before
was
noted to be likely driven by nosocomial
transmission meaning it was likely
spread within the healthcare system
so all those patients
those 53 patients
more than half of them had been in the
hospital recently there was healthcare
workers who who also had the mdr and
xdrtb and when you
when the genotyping
looking at the genetic elements of those
particular mycobacteria
the vast majority had the same
genotype so all of which indicated that
was transmitted nosocomially
there we've done studies
as well to look at
transmission outside of the hospital
and
work that was done by a phd student here
out of the school of public health
sanjay basu
did a modeling study that estimated
transmission of mdr and xdrt into the
community and that that would without
any sort of intervention or attention to
tb in this area that that community
transmission would predominate so moving
from a healthcare facility out into the
community
to that would perpetuate the epidemic
and certainly um
looking at household contacts of mdr and
xdrtb patients approximately three
percent were found to concurrently have
active tb and that
study was written a couple of years ago
and supports that
when we talk about tb infection control
there's three main components that we
are concerned with and that's
administrative controls so health care
policies
and an institution specific level that
would govern how patients move
throughout the facility to limit their
exposure um so for example if you have
someone who's coughing
and is you're concerned about them
having tb making sure that they're not
spending a lot of time sitting in your
waiting room around other patients
making sure they kind of streamline them
to get attention and by the nurse or
doctors as quickly as possible
so putting policies like that into place
personal protection so making sure all
your healthcare workers are wearing
masks respirators to protect themselves
making sure that patients who are
coughing
exhibit
cough hygiene and perhaps wearing masks
of their own to limit transmission
amongst patients
and then environmental controls
and
environmental controls can include
several things we're going to talk today
about
a project that we did effective natural
ventilation at the household level
again all of our work has been focused
on
moving away from healthcare facility
facilities and moving into the community
so this is uh the first project we'll
talk about
so we wanted to look at the effect of
natural ventilation
uh improving airflow
to diminish the risk of tb transmission
and that's been shown to be
helpful in healthcare facilities but is
it a useful tool at the community level
so in this project we went into the
community we looked at people's
traditional zulu homes
and did multiple measurements to look at
this issue so they were structure
excuse me um structural measurements
ambient air measurements including
temperature wind speed air flow
direction and then ventilation
measurements
and here the way this was done
you'll see it in the bottom right hand
corner we had a big old co2 tank
we were able to close up the entire room
released co2 from that tank in the room
and looked at the concentration
of co2 in the room using a co2 meter
and looked at the rate of decay
in parts per million
and that is able to be uh
translated into air changes per hour
looking at it then that's a calculation
looking at uh
the log of the co2 concentration over
time
and the the best fit of the slope of the
line is air changes per hour
and that's a common measurement that's
used for ventilation studies and then
using that air changes per hour estimate
and plugging that into the wells riley
equation which is the best current model
available for tv transmission
and that gives us an estimated tb risk
so you can see here that in the closed
condition i with all the doors and
windows closed
the air changes per hour were 2.4
again air changes per hour is the number
of air changes for example in a room
like this if we closed off all the doors
turned off the the fans and the ac
how much
what would it take to
how many air changes how many
times how many times could we turn over
all the air in this room take out all
the air move it out and replace it with
all new air how many times we do that in
one hour
so if everything is closed up
can the air could turn over to two and a
half times
if we open the windows a little bit
the air turns over seven point four
times
if the open the windows all the way
11.8 and if we open up the doors and
windows
21 times
where would you rather be sitting
which room would you rather be sitting
in
i'm guessing all of us would rather be
here if we had if we had the option
where would we want to live
we would want to live where we could
have this
similarly
um and correspondingly
translating this again this air changes
per hour into percent
proportion tb risk or the estimate of tv
transmission
if you are sitting in the closed
condition
with two and a half hour two and a half
air changes
or air turnovers your risk is nearly 60
of getting tv
and this is over a finite period of time
over 10 hours
and at the other extreme if your ach or
air changes for hours 21 you turn over
the air 21 times in the room your risk
is
much much less
not eliminated but much much less again
where would we all rather be i think we
would rather be
someplace where the ventilation is very
high and our risk is low
so this is what we were able to
demonstrate in people's homes
and looking at what the most important
factors were that would contribute to
air changes per hour and improving
ventilation in people's homes
we came up with two separate models
one more technical model that we thought
would be more helpful for people
building homes architects and engineers
and such
which is
window volume
ratio in addition to
opening all the doors and windows the
ventilation
that was certainly a very predictive
factor
again the bigger the windows the bigger
the volume and that relationship
would be helpful
the other model which we thought was
more a practical model and easier for
our lake community members to understand
is
the house shape and material so we found
that
people who had round uh and thatched
roofs round huts with thatched roofs did
not breathe as well as
box-shaped houses with metal roofs and
those are the two predominant styles of
construction in our area
and then again
increasing the number of windows also
helps and that all makes intuitive sense
this hasn't been really this hasn't been
looked at at all at the community level
all the work has been done in healthcare
facilities so i felt that this was
helpful information to be able to convey
to people so to understand the
importance of ventilation
and again you can see here
this top
diamond line
is closed condition and this is
estimated to be risk on the y-axis and
time
so you can see the same remains true
with increased
exposure
as the
ventilation improves from closed down to
windows open down to windows and doors
open you can see the estimated tb risk
decreases over time
if you compare
the risk at two hours in the closed
condition with everything doors and
windows closed the risk is approximately
20 percent
at 24 hours the risk is the same if you
have all the windows and doors open
again to emphasize the effect
and the
diminished risk with improved
ventilation
so we know from this work that
ventilation at baseline with all the
doors and windows closed is generally
poor and
may facilitate transmission
the use of more and larger windows and
doors
if you can open them and keep them open
would certainly diminish the risk
and this
information that we can pass along to
the local department of health so they
can we can communicate
the risk and ways to decrease the risk
to to community members
in terms of next steps is trying to
implement this for for community members
and also look at patients are sorry
community members
knowledge of infection control do they
understand ways that they can
intercede on their own behalf
and what barriers there may be to
implementing
such a strategy
okay so now we're going to move over to
the next eye intensive case finding
and what is intensive case finding
this means
this refers to
strategies to improve the diagnosis
at an earlier stage of
disease of tuberculosis to improve their
outcomes and to decrease transmission
we're actively looking for tb cases or
going out to the community or going out
and looking for people with tuberculosis
instead of waiting for them passively to
come into the health care system
i think there's questions around the
strategy in terms of um
how do we diagnose tuberculosis when
we're doing this
active searching for cases are we
looking for people with symptoms
are we going to collect a sputum for
evaluation on everybody are we going to
do a chest x-ray on everybody
what
groups are going to be at the highest
risk
which populations are we going to screen
are we only going to focus on hiv
patients are we going to look at
everybody in general
in these endemic tb settings
where are we going to screen them are we
only going to focus on the health care
facilities are we going to go outside of
that
facilities and then again who will
perform the screening
you need dedicated staff to do this but
do they need to be clinical
staff can we train
high school students to go out and
educate people and to look for people
with symptoms
as an example
so
the state of the field at this moment is
that there's been a focus on case
finding primarily in known hiv patient
populations again the highest risk group
as we described before
what we're doing
currently is a
novel community-based strategy
and we're going outside of the health
care facility to
community
where in these high prevalence tv
endemic areas
working currently with the local
department of health and what we've
launched is a tb screening effort a tb
case finding team that's integrating the
tb and hiv components
so we have a team of nurses and hiv
counselors and field health workers who
go out to various congregate community
sites
offer health education regarding tb and
hiv
offer
hiv testing if someone is found to be
hiv positive we offer them a cd4 count
a blood draw for cd4 count
we screen them for tb symptoms
if they have symptoms we collect a
sputum for smear and culture
and then we're going to follow up their
overall clinical outcomes to see are
they better off having been diagnosed
earlier
at the community level as opposed to
waiting for them to have come into the
health care system on their own
and i've just listed here the the
various community
sites that we go to
again we're trying to take advantage of
of community settings that are already
occurring
some municipality events events that the
local government is having and those
happen on a fairly regular basis pension
pay points
those are uh
the points where people come out to
get their once a month
social welfare
grant
we have a big armored truck that comes
driving out to the middle of nowhere and
stops at a certain point in a certain
day
and
hundreds of people will show up on that
particular day but any other day there's
nothing there
and they literally give out their
people's monthly social check
off the back of the truck
um
taxi ranks where there's a lot of people
crossing paths and
good site for to attract a lot of people
we do go into prisons and that's been at
the invitation and partnership with the
local
department of corrections
we were going into secondary schools
when we started
in february 2011 there became more
concern in the country about the impact
of hiv testing and diagnosis
amongst
young people and the government put a
stop to that
for the time being they're looking at
ways to optimize that kind of testing in
the future and hopefully it will resume
but for the moment that's uh there's a
moratorium on that
and then certainly health fairs and
other community events that are
occurring in the area
home-based care events
those are events organized by our local
community health workers who work in
people's local neighborhoods
and organize events to care for their
their community and they invite us in
so this is just some pictures of what
this looks like
this is
our mobile clinic
our nurses and healthcare field health
workers at a taxi rank it's a little bit
hard to appreciate the taxi rank but
you have to believe me when i say that
that's what that is
we have some people who are some others
who are also interested in our services
here in the side of the picture
this is a home-based care event so
literally out in the people's
communities in the neighborhood
under a tree and we would bring all of
our equipment with us chairs and tables
and set up where people are
one-on-one counseling and administration
of a questionnaire
this is at a secondary school i can see
the school in the distance and it
attracted people other than just the
students but people who live in the
vicinity people who worked at the school
etc
and then again this is
an exam
illustration of the health education
that's going on one of our nurses
handing out condoms
so
from march 2010 till june 2012
we have now screened more than 5 400
people at the community level over 320
visits to the community
the vast majority
of people are willing to have their hiv
tests done under these set in this
setting and under these circumstances
vast majority people
are interested in getting an hiv test
and willing to have that happen
91 percent
10
of the people that we're testing or
people that were screening in this kind
of environment are hiv positive
um are identified as hiv positive
we are as i said we offer for those who
are hiv positive we offer phlebotomy for
cd4 count
the vast majority is taking advantage of
that
and the median cd4 count is
379. um
and when we deliver these results to
them we bring the blood back with us to
the hospital and then once we have a
result we go and find them again to
deliver the results and counsel them
with the appropriate next step
so currently the criteria for starting
antiretroviral therapy is 350.
so if we find a cd4 count result of
475 we can go back to that
patient and say you need to recheck your
cd4 count in the next three to six
months and but currently you do not
qualify for intuitive therapy
if we have a cd4 count of 180 and go
back to that patient say you qualified
for antiretroviral therapy right now you
need to get to the clinic and start the
process of getting onto the drugs
on the tb side
i've identified nearly a thousand tb
suspects
people with symptoms who were able to
give us the sputum
for microbiological examination
the vast majority have
their predominant symptom being cough
greater than two weeks
you can see that 15
are zeal nielsen or mean smear positive
so a very low proportion
35 or 3.7 overall have microbiologically
confirmed tb and that means smear or
culture
and does not double count the smear or
culture
results so there was four patients who
we had an afb positive without a
supporting culture
17 patients who had drug susceptible tb
nearly half and another
more than a quarter had drug resistant
tb
that we were able to identify at the
community level
all 10
of these patients were identified once
we had the culture result we were able
to go back to them and found them that
they were still alive
and we were able to refer them into care
in contrast to
the current
uh or historical situation where by the
time we identify patients whether they
come into the health care system we get
a culture and by the time we get the
culture results which take
a month or two to come back at a minimum
we go back and find that half of the
patients have already passed away
because of that diagnostic delay
but in this case we're able to find
everybody and get them referred into the
health care system
and then we did have a few where the
drug susceptibility testing was
contaminated or
is still pending at this point
but we knew it's it's
culture positive tb
and you can say that there's
approximately a month
that it takes before we're able to get a
final culture and drug susceptibility
testing result
oh there we go
so
is this strategy
and the people that we're finding
or testing
in this environment are they
representative of the general population
or are there some differences
excuse me
um we looked at approximately 153
patients uh in a subset that represented
people who were participating in the icf
services and those who were not
participating and basically there was
really no difference in terms of
socioeconomic status or demographics
or in terms of previous hiv or tb
testing or treatment
so that was uh in that would indicate to
us that this is strategy is reaching a
representative sample of the population
and that the figures and epidemiology
that we're seeing here are
representative
so among the
91 percent that
did have a hiv test
the vast majority are women and that's
reflective of our local population
most of the men end up going elsewhere
to find work
and the vast majority three quarters
will
remain our
adults are women
the
it's a somewhat slightly older age group
than what we were expecting we think of
when we think of targeting hiv services
we think of
younger populations who are in theory
more sexually active but clearly
the people who are taking advantage of
the service are slightly older than we
would have thought
almost half of the people were
undergoing an hiv test for the first
time
and that was a bit surprising to us
we thought that we were going into the
community and targeting a population who
did not or had left poorer access to
services we actually thought that this
would be a lot higher
so 50 percent the other way to look at
is a 50 percent
have had a previous hiv test and are
undergoing serial testing
so the public health education that's
occurring
about hiv in this area is seeming to be
effective and people are recognizing
risk factors in their own lives and or
seeking out
taking advantage of the service
again among the nearly 500 that were
identified as hiv positive
of the people who were first time
testers
12 and a half 13 percent weren't hiv
positive
um of the people who had been
tested previously
seven and a half were or seven point
seven percent were known to be positive
previously
so again people are
retesting
anecdotally
what we're hearing from people is that
their previous
testing experience
was not a good testing experience they
had
had some level of mistrust with the
person providing the test or the
environment in which it happened
or
what people are we're hearing is that
people were diagnosed as positive
previously they sought out a cure from a
traditional healer
and then
they're coming and testing with us to
confirm whether or not that cure worked
so again this is anecdotal we haven't um
evaluate that in a more system
systematic way but
uh it certainly is very interesting that
a lot of people knew that they were
positive are coming to us for repeat
services
that was a surprise
again 40 42
of all of the patients
that tested with us knew that they were
positive already
and this
this is work that was done by a student
who worked with us before
again a short-term questionnaire looking
at people's motivations
again the vast majority are female
approximately 39 years
was the mean
but in terms of why people were testing
for hiv
12.6 percent recognized that they had
some sort of lifestyle issue that put
them at risk for hiv infection
very few people were testing because
they were pregnant we can only assume
that people were being caught by the
antenatal care services
of the government
and others were being tested just
because they were not feeling well
so again this needs to be further
evaluated
the people who said that they were
feeling ill
ultimately had lower cd4 counts
again people are recognizing the
possibility of hiv infections in their
in their lives
new hiv diagnosis were more likely to
test the known hiv diagnoses
due to concern for a risky lifestyle
and then
in another survey that we had with a
student we had approximately 287
community members against screeners and
non-screeners who were surveyed
and in terms of their knowledge of tb
and hiv disease
and
societies suffice the the blue is the tb
and the red is the hiv and you can see
on a score
of 16 questions related to tb and hiv
disease separate
questionnaires
the overall knowledge of
tb was lower than that of hiv
i think what we take away from this is
that the public health education has
been wonderful about hiv and there's
been a lot of progress that's been made
but even though tb has been around a lot
longer there's less knowledge or less
accurate knowledge about what
is involved with tb
transmission the causes of disease and
and potentially treatment
okay so coming back to our our community
work
it was important to us
to
utilize a variety of different community
congregate settings to
identify people i think initially when
we started out
thinking about this work we thought we
would
only focus on pension pay points
thinking we get a nice cross-section of
people and population i think over time
we learned or very early on we learned
that that was going to be insufficient
and that we needed to use a variety of
different sites
so you can see that the in terms of the
numbers screened at each of these
different types of sites the number that
were number in proportion positive by
sight
the most common uh
place where we had hiv positive patients
the highest proportion were in prisons
and taxi ranks
followed by health fairs and
municipality events
fortunately very few
hiv-positive people in schools but again
that was a very small number because of
the moratorium that was put into place
what did what predicted
hiv positivity in this community sample
so age marital status the fact that they
previously had an hiv test so remember i
said many people knew that they were
already positive
having contact with a tb patient in the
last 12 months
whether they're on current tb treatment
the type of community site which we
talked about just in the last slide and
other clinical factors whether they've
had a lot of respiratory infections
they've had shingles or thrush
in terms of symptoms
there's a variety of different symptoms
here that were associated with having a
positive hiv status
on the tb side
again the number of the different
congregate sites the number of people
screened at each site the number of tb
suspects
in terms of people who gave us a
specimen
at each site the proportion at each site
overall we had approximately a quarter
of all people we screened that had tb
symptoms
and the number and proportion uh
microbiologically confirmed at each time
site so you can see that uh the rate or
2.7 percent was the highest in prisons
followed by taxi ranks and then health
health fairs and
municipality events and home-based care
so
quite a spectrum there
and then again what predicts
tb in this community sample
so gender
not having electricity
the type of community site that we just
talked about
interestingly
i think something that we were very
surprised about is that hiv status did
not predict
tb in this community sample
and we'll talk about that more in one
minute
in terms of symptoms
cough
greater than two weeks or cough of any
duration um
night sweats and weight loss chest pain
and shortness of breath
those are things that intuitively do
make sense to us
so
looking at the overall summary of what
this work has shown so far
um
i'll just focus on on this column right
here in terms of microbiologically
confirmed tb in this community sample
looking at a rate of 641 per 100 000
meaning we would need to screen nns is
the number needed to screen there's a
common measure in screening studies
we need to screen 156 people to find
one
patient with tb
and i've put down here the the rate of
smear positive or microbially confirmed
rates
in our by from our local health
department
so 24 to 29 percent of the tb that's
captured by the health care facilities
is smear positive
the rest are clinical diagnoses
and approximately 274 per 100 000 in the
health care facilities so we're finding
what we're finding in the community
sample is
certainly
the same or much higher than what we're
seeing in the healthcare facilities in
terms of microbiologically confirmed
tuberculosis
one limitation of that is that this does
include culture um these are these are
just mere positive cases but that's the
local practice it's the best we can
compare to at this point
so
again
in in the province approximately 70 to
80 percent of the tb
is hiv co-infected
in our area
uh from the same from the health care
facilities we know that approximately 64
of all the cases of tb that have been
diagnosed in our healthcare facility at
our hospital
are hiv co-infected but what we're
seeing is approximately 8.5 percent
hiv co-infection which is significantly
different
from
what we're seeing in the healthcare
facilities
again that was a
surprise to us
and our
our speculation is that what we're
seeing at the community level is a large
reservoir of tb in non-hiv-infected
patient populations and what we're
seeing come into the health facilities
are the particularly vulnerable and
susceptible people who get sick
and become ill much more rapidly with
active disease
with colleagues here at the yale school
of public health dr paul tl dr galvani
and jennifer gilbert
we've been able to start to model what
the impact of this strategy would be
the
looking at
for example this
the lowest line here on the left
is an icf that
strategy that covers 15 percent of the
population per year
you can see the number of tb cases that
would be averted almost 500 over the
next 10 years if you were to expand this
to 90 percent of the population
every year and that's represented by the
purple line here over the next 10 years
you have the
possibility of averting 2500 cases
similarly on the hiv side
with ninety percent of the
of the population getting intensive case
finding fourteen hundred cases of hiv
could be averted
so what's happening to these patients
that we're identifying and this is uh
preliminary outcomes work at this point
um just on the hiv side i'll point out
that again of those 500 people who we've
identified as hiv positive 135
of them
are eligible
for antiretroviral therapy on the basis
of their cd4 count of 350.
only 30 percent of those patients have
initiated antiretroviral therapy as of
yet
among those who have initiated their
median cd4 count as 247 but it's still
taking them quite a long time
to get into into care
so when we started this work we thought
that the biggest obstacle for people was
knowing what their status was i getting
an hiv test and perhaps getting a cd4
count because of the lengthy delays in
the healthcare system in terms of
getting those tests done
but i think what we're finding is that
this despite the fact that we're going
out to the patient not waiting for them
to come to the health care system that
there are still other obstacles
that were need that we need to
evaluate and address before we can get
everybody who needs to be in care into
care
in terms of next steps here we are in
the process of analyzing the data to
look at see if we can identify any
differences predicting
those patients who actually started
anti-brush brow therapy
so what does this all mean
that community-based intensive case
finding is an effective strategy for
early case detection for both tb and hiv
that using a variety of congregate
settings is very important
that
the epidemiology
is very different at the community level
than at in the health care facilities
which is the basis for most of the
literature of the published
and available
literature
that we can identify tb and drug
resistant tb at an earlier stage of
disease
and potentially have an influence on
mortality
that work is in progress
that we have a substantially lower
proportion of hiv tb co-infection at the
community level
in this in this rural uh sub-saharan
african setting
and that the the overall rates of
microbial microbiologically confirmed tb
are high at the in the community level
on the hiv side certainly improving hiv
diagnosis
is feasible at a community level
people are accepting those kinds of
services in this environment
that we need to provide comprehensive
services not just hiv testing but
the addition of cd4 count testing
but that certainly
educating and providing
information to patients about their
status and even their cd4 count does not
and making them aware that they are
eligible for treatment does not
translate into
increased
art initiation
so we need to identify the other
obstacles
and address those
okay
quickly going through icinized and
preventive therapy what is isonized
preventive therapy
ipt isolated preventive therapy is a
strategy recommended for all hiv
positive patients regardless of age
pregnancy status cd4 count and whether
or not they've had a history of tb or
not
what it is is daily isonize it again
remember that that's one of the
anti-tb drugs and one of the most potent
ones
you take isoniazid daily for six months
and
will that will reduce your overall
incidence of tuberculosis in the future
how long does that effect last
currently the best estimates are that if
you take it for six months it'll reduce
your incidence of tb for another 18
months or so
right now it's being offered only to
those patients in in south africa it's
being offered only to those patients who
are already in hiv care i.e those with a
cd4 count less than 350 we're already
getting
art
and our project
that we're starting up now is to
implement ipt among those individuals
identified through icf at the community
level
a population that's been neglected thus
far
so we already among those eligible for
ipt in our in our current sample
those who are already getting art
approximately 30 are receiving or have
already completed six months of ipt
so we know that it's feasible
we have another 300 people who
are not eligible or are not eligible for
art
but eligible for ipt but are not
currently able to access it so this
project is going to implement ipt among
those eligible people and look at
treatment outcomes and adherence
and then other
uh
future plans that we're
starting
is an evaluation of a rapid point of
care cd4 count essay
to evaluate this tool in a community
setting not in a healthcare setting but
in out in the field
and compare it to the standard
phlebotomized sample
and also
look at its use in
non-clinical hands so most laboratory
tests are done
by clinicians by nurses
and we're going to look at whether or
not this test can be done by an hiv
counselor who's not been clinically
trained
again that would expand
the reach of comprehensive hiv services
at the community level
including being less reliant on highly
skilled individuals
and allow us to decentralize hiv
services
and this is about this project is about
to start
so in general
the world health organization's three
eyes is a comprehensive platform for
combating tuberculosis
and at our site in south africa we're in
the process of developing and
implementing community-based
interventions on all three fronts
infection control intensive case finding
and isonized preventive therapy
to
foster
an effort to
detect
tb and hiv earlier
in an earlier stage of disease and
overall to improve patient outcomes and
decrease transmission
several people that to acknowledge
certainly
jerry friedland who's here in the
audience
lori andrews from the aids program are
collaborators in south africa anthony
mall and june tombow tosses
karaokes
from the school of public health uh
devashipati sarasani and melissa logisos
from who are students who've worked with
us
ralph brooks from the aids program uh my
other mentors
rick altis rob doral dan zelterman and a
whole host of
funding agencies who've been
instrumental to getting this work done